hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast and ah
i'm just checking in on you
i almost didn't say that right i'm just
checking in on you seeing how the [ __ ]
you're doing i'm sitting in a swivel
chair
i'm doing this podcast before i fly out
to saint louis oh
meet me in saint
[Music]
meet me at the fair
don't tell me the lights are shining
every place but there
we will dance what the [ __ ]
this is what happens when your first
record your your mother buys you is uh
mitch miller sing along with mitch in
the gang won't you come home bill bailey
the other kids are listening to [ __ ]
aerosmith and led zeppelin
and i'm coming in five foot two eyes of
blue but of what those five foots could
do has anybody seen my gal
and orange hair and just moved the new
kid
how are you who would like to kick the
[ __ ] out of me first
[Music]
christ i never had a chance um
anyway um
yes i'm going to st louis
i'm doing a show there wednesday and
thursday so it's all right whenever you
listen to this [ __ ] i got one more i
hope last night went good
and uh
then i go back to uh red rocks to do the
second show
make sure my beard is trimmed the exact
same way
you know
i know what setting i had it on i know
it was two days before when i clipped it
so i shoot this and i put it together
hopefully it matches
you know but now that i said that
somebody could say um i noticed your
beard
wasn't quite the same side did you
is that what you noticed
i noticed
who the [ __ ] has time to notice
something like that and in cell
[Laughter]
ah jesus you know the internet is really
just becoming just a bunch of towny bars
you know any place you go into everybody
looks at you and you got to think the
way they do or they chase you out of the
[ __ ] bar
it's [ __ ] mobs just little mobs of
people
um why can't everybody
be perfect like me you know
i you know i i just i know to look at me
you don't see perfection
you know but maybe that's part of my
disguise if you watch like the nature
channel like
you know some of the most uh some of the
species that have lived the longest is
because they they know how to survive by
blending in
so you know
i'm just playing a role
i actually have a full head of jet black
hair
you
know i'm part of the illuminati i just
wear this ball like a bald cap
um
anyway i'm excited to be here in st
louis even though i'm not here yet but i
might as well say that because you're
listening i will be here
i will be there
i'll be there don't you know babe
remember that guy who sang
on uh
on [ __ ] uh mariah carey she did a
cover of that and then she let that guy
do the solo
and he was like
all [ __ ] way up there back when
singing [ __ ] way up there was what
everybody was trying to do i pointed at
the ceiling both times when i said that
way up there in case you guys don't know
what that means
um
he was supposed to blow up he must have
done something that guy crushed it
mtv unplugged oh man those were the days
that was though we didn't realize that
was almost it wasn't quite the end of
the day
but it was rapidly changing and then
they had trl live that was sort of the
last
that was the last thing that ever
happened then i don't know what happened
but you know for the reality [ __ ] that
they had you know the real world was
good
you know
teen mom
according to nate bargatsi was [ __ ]
tremendous
i never even really watched teen mom but
if if it [ __ ]
nate's bid on it was was worth that show
air being aired
[Laughter]
um if you've never seen it look it up
i'm sure it's out there i'm sure it's
out there in the what do they call it
the the the
ellipticies
i don't know the zeitgeist
um
so let's talk my history here
in st louis what have i done in saint
louis well what i found out is that you
know like a lot of cities
you know that once we're kicking us and
then now they're not
and everybody left
you know they see cities you got the
rust belt cities and then you got the uh
the white flight cities
like right in the late 60s early 70s you
had race riots and then you had all
these [ __ ] uh all this industry
leaving
the united states simply because
you know they didn't want to deal with
the unions anymore
i think i mean that's what people in in
my bars told me i'm not gonna look it up
i'm not gonna have a guest on this
podcast that's an expert i'm not doing
that that's basically what happened
right
you know i don't know
then they all [ __ ] left so you had
like these rust belt towns and then you
had like these towns that were sort of
[ __ ] burned up or whatever and they
never really rebuilt them
and that was that was the road that i
knew
you know when you went out in the
midwest you know we started out down
near baltimore and then he kind of
worked way out there to [ __ ] say it
was
um
he just went through these [ __ ]
cities like jesus christ what the [ __ ]
happened now they look great like
pittsburgh
pittsburgh i mean it looks amazing
um didn't look amazing when i first got
there
you know i'm sure buffalo's coming back
buffalo did not look good when i first
came there
you know that was in the 2000s 2000
you're like oh jeez
this whole town looks hungover
right forget about cleveland
i used to have to get escorted after the
show
back to the [ __ ] hotel
um
and if you played it in the wintertime
when the sun was already down you got
escorted to and from
um and st louis was one of those places
there was well there was a lot of these
towns cincinnati you were there downtown
was happening and then right at five
o'clock
right after five o'clock like you could
not get you could not get anything to
eat
every [ __ ] restaurant every little
[ __ ] thing closed up everybody got in
their [ __ ] cars and just left and
then all of a sudden you're like in the
middle of a zombie movie
you know during the day you'd see people
walking around doing the thing but then
they just [ __ ] and they let when
everybody go
and st louis was one of these cities
where i remember i used to play uh the
funny bone
and um
is it what was it westport is that what
it was the westport funny bone i played
that you know every
year or so they'd bring me back and i
would go to games i had a blast playing
that place i when the first game i went
to was at uh bush stadium
the saint louis god knows
they might have played the pirates i
don't remember a long time ago and i
came back another time and i went to the
news the new one
which i don't know what that was
the bud light.com
stadium whatever the [ __ ] they called it
they stopped you know i guess it would
still be cool because it was named after
a beer whatever that was a bad example
jobbing.com arena they still got that
one in [ __ ]
arizona
anyway so i went to that one i got to
see mark mcguire
who had a buddy of mine back in boston
buddy of mine gary i've known him for
[ __ ] almost 40 years he put the
steroid error
in baseball into perspective like nobody
else
he said steroids saved baseball
and i think he's right i think after
that strike in 1994
they had one little bit of momentum and
that was cal ripken junior breaking the
record
and then other than that nobody gave a
[ __ ] well i guess the yankees getting
good again that was great a yankee
dynasty
you know that's always good for baseball
as far as like making people pay
attention and all that and then they can
you know because baseball's all about
the past
and they could start [ __ ] digging up
scooter mcgee and all these [ __ ]
people you know
um
[ __ ] footage of world war ii and all
this [ __ ] that they do
um
but yeah
it [ __ ] saved baseball
it was unbelievable
guys you never heard of
50 home runs in the middle of august it
was [ __ ] phenomenal
and i think like steroids like weed
eventually
will be legal
and who knows maybe sammy sosa and mark
mcguire they look they are looked at as
pioneers well i guess they'd be more
like lalzedo you have to go further back
you know
some of those teams
from the 70s right
i don't know i don't have a problem with
[ __ ] steroids
i don't especially like you know
yeah they're out there they're beating
the [ __ ] out of their bodies you see how
some of these guys walk after they're
playing football
it's like why can't you just make them
bionic during the season why can't you
do that what is what is
the pro it isn't fair
it's like well you know life isn't fair
you know sports is a metaphor
you know you see all these different
races of people they all come together
and they work together as a team
you know and it makes you feel good but
then secretly you find out they're doing
a bunch of underhunted you know
underhanded [ __ ]
which goes into the whole you know there
really is no santa claus
i choose to think that santa claus
is the spirit it's the christmas spirit
and if you accept it and you bring it in
then
i actually agree with that once you have
kids
you know you got to go
all the [ __ ] out all the [ __ ] out all
the way up
there was no reason to curse in that i
just i think i just panicked in the
middle of that phrase that he threw all
the you got to go all the [ __ ] when it
comes to kids you got to go all the [ __ ]
out that's what i just said that would
be the end of my presidential campaign
uh
what the uh
senator was trying to say was
you got to go all out
that's what he's trying to say
why do you think he used the f word and
right after he said children was there
something going on there we vehemently
deny that we're not i'm not even gonna
answer that you just did well i
shouldn't have
okay
and i think that this is coming from the
right and the left
um
yeah i went to a st louis blues game
i went to a [ __ ]
st louis rams game
and uh
i mean i don't know you think with all
that beer money they would have they
could have built a better state and that
stadium was just
that was a strange stadium who the [ __ ]
did was the quarterback
it's the one version always gave me [ __ ]
about i i believed in the guy was like
he just hasn't played on a good team
yet um he ended up playing going to the
vikings what the [ __ ] was his name
anyways uh was the rams verse uh the
[ __ ] did they play i don't remember
but anyways used to go to blues bars out
there they got a lot of live music i
took a [ __ ] tour up into that goddamn
arch
a lot of people don't know you can
actually go up into the arch it's one of
the scariest tourist attractions i've
ever been to you get into basically what
looks like the egg from mork and mindy
and it's sort of like it i don't know
what the linkage is to get you up there
because you know it is an arch you're
going up to
i just know you keep going up a level
and then you stop and then the thing
just sort of swings
like you know when you're on a ferris
wheel and there's some douche and it
wants to start swinging it right as
you're at the top
because they want to scare the [ __ ] out
of you because their dad was sadistic
and you're kind of like hey man like i
thought this was going to be a chill out
ride
um it does that the whole way up
and then you get up to the top of it and
it is designed to sway a little bit
like some of these buildings like you
can feel them moving and it's really
[ __ ] unsettling especially if you go
to look out the windows you lit you're
laying
in a prone position and that thing is
moving back and forth and a little fun
fact
some skydiver
i don't know what he was thinking tried
to land on top of the thing
so he came in he landed he slipped and
fell
and then slid down the side of it and
his chute couldn't open you know because
it started to collapse
and then he died
i gotta confirm that i know that
happened
i know that happened hang on a second uh
sky diver
st louis
arch
dead
see i know how to google 40 years ago
first parish shooting stunt at the arch
ends in tragedy
november 22nd 1980
skydiver falls to death at arch
this guy with the afro and the [ __ ]
mustache
the gateway arch shaped like a magnet
experts
exerts a powerful pull on pilots and
parachutes yeah probably pilots want to
fly right down the middle of it and long
before
fair saint louis featured sanctions
events there were daredevil who
attempted to conquer the arch on their
own the first parachute who tried
parachuters who tried fell to his death
in the process
he was
kenneth
w
swyers 33 of overland who parachuted
from an airplane on the morning of
november 22nd
1980 and touched the top of the arch but
before he could jump with a second
parachute he slid down the north leg of
the arch
and stuck in and struck the pavement
see they wrote [ __ ] a lot more blunt
even in 1980. he was dead before anyone
could rush to his side
friends said swires had intended to land
on the arch but had merely meant to
oh hadn't intended to land on the arch
but merely meant to sail between its
legs
as many a pilot had done before him
maybe he called an audible
he went peyton manning there four months
before workers completed the arch the
federal aviation administration issued a
stern warning to would-be stunt pilots
don't even think about it but they
thought about it and they did it the
stunts began on june 22nd 1966 when a
twin-engine aircraft zipped between
beneath
startled taurus oh my god at the top of
the arch
see back in the day you
back in the day i think you'd get away
with that because you could fly below
radar at that point
and just sort of dip back up
and like
i don't know i don't know how that
[ __ ] works but there's no way you
could do that today there'd be a million
cell phone something somebody would get
you
uh it took more than 50 years to reveal
the name of that pilot in 2016 donna
dorris from madison illinois told the
post dispatch that her father
earl bolen was the pilot she said the
family has held onto the story as a
secret for five decades
other flights are reported jesus christ
maniacs december 12 1969 five days later
december 17th
april 16 1971
october 8 71
1-2 and then
nobody until 77 then an 81 another one
in 81.
some insist they have photos of another
plane making it through in late april 71
but the photos are fuzzy and the event
is graded as unconfirmed
after the third flight officials put up
a 500 reward but nobody ever claimed it
in fact the faa has never been able to
nail an airplane pilot
but somebody got the number of a
helicopter of course because we're slow
as [ __ ] that went through the legs on
april 6 1984.
uh the faa tracked down the pilot his
name like his fate has been lost in the
midst of time
oh
jesus
so there you go i'm in st louis
everybody
everybody comes here for the blues music
and the barbecue but who knows you know
you can fly to their tourist attractions
nobody seems to figure it out um okay
it's babel everybody you know when
you're traveling to a destination where
you don't know the language it can be
challenging to accomplish even the
simplest of tasks
yeah you're trying to score some [ __ ]
coke in thailand you want to know how to
say it thankfully there's babel the
number one selling language learning app
through babel's bite size lessons you'll
learn new skills
that you can actually use in the real
world i said get off me you can say that
in china
uh chinese from greetings menus and
directions to gaining a deeper
understanding of the culture babel
is a travel essential
babel's 15-minute lessons will make the
perfect way to learn a new language
on the go i didn't do anything she came
at me in french
other language
just assuming you're the ugly american
you're going to get involved in some
issues
are the language learning apps
use ai for lesson plans but babel's
lessons were created by over 100
language experts their teaching method
has been scientifically proven to be
effective
with babel you can choose from 14
different languages including spanish
french italian
german
plus babel's speech recognition
technology helps you to improve your
pronunciation and accent there's so many
ways to learn with babel in addition to
lessons you can access podcast games
video stories and even live classes
i want to do this start your new
language learning journey today with
babel bonjour today
right now
when you purchase a three month babel
subscription you'll get an additional
three months for free that's six months
for the price of three just go to
babel.com and use the promo code bird
that's babel
b-a-b-b-e-l.com
code burr b-u-r-r babble language for
life
language for life
all right
now look oh look who it is old zip
according to forbes
gyms nail salons hotels mom and pop
stores and more
are uh are set to go on an epic hiring
spree
oh according to forbes gyms nail salons
hotels mom and pop stores
and more are set to go on an epic hiring
spree in the coming months to meet the
pent-up demand for all those services in
other words your checks are going to run
out and you got to go back to work your
bums
all these businesses reopening means
that millions of jobs will be needed to
be need to be filled
so
where
where do these businesses turn to fill
these rules
zip back
up right now you can try it for free
that's it
dot com slash burr when you put when you
post a job on ziprecruiter they send
your job to over 100 top job sites
giving you access to their networks
for millions of job seekers zip
credit
as matching technology scans resumes to
find qualified candidates for your first
open oh for your open roles and
perfectly presents them to you zip
recruiters technology is so effective
that four to five employees who post
unzip recruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day and right now you
can try zip
for free at the exclusive web address
ziprecruiter.com
recruiter r-e-c-r-u-i-t-e-r
dot com slash burr
burb urr just go to ziprecruiter.com
zip
the smartest way to hire anyway
drinking a root beer here this is all i
got people
it's my big vice this and [ __ ]
15 cigars a month that's not 15 but it's
it's getting up there
um
what do you want from me huh people
that old man sliding down the other side
of the arch what do you want um
yeah i'm back at the gym
okay and i've been throwing the weights
around
all right i did my lat pull downs today
i'm up to 40 pounds
sets of 10 which is huge
it's huge for me with my [ __ ] up
goddamn rotator cuff you know
i used to complain it like [ __ ] 10
pounds so now if i can just do that what
i do is i get it up where i can do like
uh sets of uh 15.
and it's one two down and then one two
three four
up you know what i mean so you get the
negative [ __ ] too right whatever you
call that part of it the shoulders down
and back or whatever so i'm not pinching
anything everything the form is good the
back is straight
my head is forward looking to the future
all right you got to watch out on that
one because if some chick walks by your
little superhero outfit you want to
check out her ass you know in that
motion if you turn you can [ __ ]
mess up your neck
um
yeah so i've been uh actually doing the
weights and i've been loving it and uh
i plan on once i get you know
past
you know getting my instrument check
ride next month hopefully i pass
um then i'll have a little bit of a
window and i can actually
[ __ ] relax cause i'll have taped it's
gonna be great man i'll taped
what could be my special which might may
just be something i'm just keeping and
i'll
put it out there someday i don't know
um
it'll definitely be on vinyl at some
point
those performances
um
and then i'll have the [ __ ]
helicopter [ __ ] behind me
f is for family is wrapped
season five is is gonna be announced i
don't know when but it it should be
announced i don't know the next four to
six weeks hopefully i don't know
so that's done oh billy clearing the
[ __ ] table here
all right so all i'll really have to
deal with at that point if i do all of
that [ __ ] is my stand-up dates
going back to flying just for fun
you know and watching the rest of the
football season
yeah so after i'm here in st louis um
i'm gonna go yeah i go back to boulder
colorado you know one of the greatest uh
hotels i ever stayed at this is all like
bill reminiscing about the road in these
cities
um
i went to uh i don't even know where the
[ __ ] i was at maybe somebody from
colorado can help me out here
let me get a map here
colorado
map
i want to thank that person that taught
me how to google search
maps colorado
here we go
okay so i did a gig in like colorado
springs i believe
i believe i did this
gig um what's that r kelly bill
open the door
uh colorado springs yes i believe is
colorado springs and i stay just west of
the city in like this valley just into
like the mountains and it looked like a
big old house
and i remember going to that and i was
working with lawhead and i was like i
gotta bring my wife back here and i've
never done the gig again there was i
remember there was an air force base or
something nearby
off the 25
south
um
if anybody knows the name of it would be
[ __ ] great
to help me out there
and um
we ended up we had a great show and then
afterwards there was this great [ __ ]
bar playing country music and all that
we had [ __ ] beers and just
hanging out it's just an amazing
amazing gig and it was just oh we went
for a hike that day
we went for a hike and i almost broke my
[ __ ] arm or my i can't remember my
arm or my leg it was gonna be my femur
or the humerus two biggest bones i just
remember i was standing up talking to
jay and then all of a sudden i was just
on the ground we were like
standing looking where we hiked i don't
know what happened i just [ __ ]
i just i went down like somebody shot me
with a [ __ ] blow dart i still don't
know how that happened
and i can't remember if i fell on my leg
my i think was my arm cause i put my arm
down i can't [ __ ] believe i didn't
snap my [ __ ] arm
but uh he was like jesus christ you are
right i'll go dude
i'm like that's how you [ __ ] like oh
[ __ ] you would have to carry me out of
here
you were joking about how you'd be like
all right man i'll [ __ ] i'm gonna go
for help
here's my hoodie try to [ __ ] stay uh
try to stay warm
um so anyway and then i got minneapolis
to close it out and i remember
minneapolis
you know i went to the vikings i went to
a vikings game who by the way i got [ __ ]
from vikings fan when i'm talking about
the best stadiums in the league they're
like what about minnesota you only bring
up the [ __ ] vikings because i haven't
been to the stadium
to be honest with you
last time i went to that stadium you
guys were in the hubert humphrey homer
dome
and i believe
randy moss was on your team i don't
think he was playing because they were
selling free randy
orange like jail orange like [ __ ]
t-shirts outside the stadium
i want to say he was playing but they
just kept those souvenirs that was one
like i think he
the the meter maid told him to stop and
he kind of you know she had her hand on
the car and he was just inching along
like half a mile an hour but it is a car
so that's considered assault with a
deadly weapon so
something like that not saying you know
i'm not downplaying what he did
or it didn't do i don't [ __ ] know
what happened um
yeah that's what i think of i think of
that i think of going to the mall of
america and riding the roller coaster by
myself just because i i was like
10 days into a college run of of dates
going up to like [ __ ] duluth and
everything
and i was just like
i hadn't really
you know i was touring by myself
i had no opening act no nothing and i
was just going from community college to
community college all around
you know south dakota iowa
and minnesota oh and did i mention it
was the dead of winter
so it was just overcast skies meats
[ __ ]
sheared off corn stalks
it was gray it was bleak the snow was
dirty
you know there were a lot of subway
sandwiches being eaten
and stacks of ihop pancakes as i was
getting through these [ __ ] gigs
and uh
i remember uh
how did i end up at the mall of america
i can't remember if i went there because
some relatives went there i think they
drove all the way up from nebraska
just to [ __ ] see it
or if it was because
it was the site where the um
minnesota north stars
arena used to be
i don't remember what but anyway i went
in there oh there was comedy clubs in
there that's what it was i was doing
business i was gonna try to pop my head
in and [ __ ] here's my headshot and my
vhs tape this is how long ago it was
um
and yeah so i haven't really spoken
anybody other than my agent
and so i was really lonely and i just
thought like
how could i make this even lonelier what
if i rode a roller coaster by myself
inside of a mall
i just did it for the laugh and i just
sat on the last cart and i did it
and uh
it wasn't funny and it wasn't sad it was
just sort of stupid and then i left
[Laughter]
i saw the timberwolves at the old target
center
i went to a minnesota wild game i went
to a twins game
at the old uh homer dome i took a tour
of the new place the new ballpark looked
great but i never went to a game there
but i went
the twins and that's when um what's his
face last time i saw cal ripton jr play
these these are a long [ __ ] time ago
go back like over 20 years i feel
um
and then of course i went got a juicy
lucy with [ __ ] paul versi
and they told him don't bite into it
because they basically to take a cube of
[ __ ] cheese and they stick it in the
hamburger patty and for whatever reason
with cheeses it gets like lava hot and
paul did not listen
and he kept biting and going ah
and we're just laughing paul cut it out
just wait cut it in half and wait
and he just kept doing it
and we were just [ __ ]
laughing our ass off at him so
um there you go that's my those are my
midwest stories all right which were
probably mid-level [ __ ] interesting
um all right we gotta do a little uh
advertising here
and uh after
the uh podcast
um
no no before the podcast ends yo i know
again i play oh i play speaking of versi
we play the uh the monday night uh
monday football we play the uh
bet uh mgm our nfl picks of the week the
week the week i got my ass kicked again
this week
jesus christ
um
the [ __ ] is my seasonal record
i don't know you'll know what it is
because you'll hear me [ __ ] bitching
about it and so enjoy that here it is
right here
[Applause]
as you all know by now we've teamed up
with bet mgm this season we'll be using
bad mgm lines to make all of our picks
and we'll have special offers for our
listeners each week there's a lot of
options out there but we've partnered
with bed mgm because they are the brand
you can trust
uh it's easy to deposit and withdraw
winnings plus they've got awesome offers
available to their customers each week
uh if you haven't signed up yet
and have been waiting for the big
splashy number to make oh i used to do
that
to make your first bet uh we've got the
perfect offer for you yeah you always
wait people would wait and be like this
is the one um sign up and use bonus code
burr doesn't get easier b-u-r-r
and you could place your get ready for
this get ready for this because i mean
this is
you place your first bet risk-free up to
a up to a big one a thousand that's one
stack
okay if you lose your wager you get your
stack back up to a thousand
in free bets what's with these kids
today paul they don't have to peddle
their bicycles anymore they got electric
skateboards they lose a grand of the
bookie and they still get it back oh my
god i used to lose a couple hundred be
petrified i could get they're giving you
a stack okay for free just sign up and
make sure you use bonus code bird
b-u-r-r it's four initials and two are
the same
when you sign up to get a thousand
dollars risk-free okay plus they've got
scooters laying all over the place
anytime they want them
i mean you could put that thousand on a
game win it you're up 2 000 and just go
crazy next thing you know you're up
that's what bet mgm is doing right now
um
and now it's time bill to talk about our
picks this week i don't know about you
can we play some sad music for me i was
sitting at giant stadium at life stadium
excuse me
uh you know there's a one listener it's
actually life stadium these lunatics um
i was sitting there with my family on
eli manning bobble head day and ring of
honor day
and at one point like a gentleman and at
one point bill i knew it wasn't gonna
happen but you know you get that five
minutes of looking at scores you're like
all right the giants are up six they
covered
the jacksonville jaguars are beating the
cardinals oh my god can i do the under
the unimaginable and go four-and-oh of
course not but i did win um the lions
and the titans i ended up two and two
and i know you were at a football game
but then you you went 0-2 at the one
o'clock game so then all of a sudden oh
you got to be you went from thinking i'm
going 4-0 to my the the the
what is that the unimaginable to you
maybe now i'm going to do the
unthinkable at 0-4. oh no the
unforgivable yeah unforgivable sorry
i went i went from the unimaginable
thought to the unforgivable in the same
hour and a half window [ __ ] myself
but i ended up going i ended up going
two and two luckily but it was a weird
week it was a weird week all right so
here's my deal i go to the uh sofi
sofi stadium
in englewood california which is the
most insane
football stadium i have ever been to bar
none all of the new ones i got some [ __ ]
from viking fans i haven't been to
theirs yet i didn't even know that they
were in the running
did they build some crazy new stadium i
knew they had a new stadium i didn't
know it was crazy they built one they're
all coming the raiders the vikings yeah
i don't know how you top this one dude
from the pictures i saw it looked insane
you went down like [ __ ] 20 escalators
to get down into it
all right you're going in i i felt like
i was going into a macy's a bill
i saw white pillars and i was in
oh it's ridiculous
i felt like i was in a mob bosses like
waiting room like the foyer
and i'm waiting for him to come down
those stairs like what kind of mood is
he going to be in you know am i getting
whacked or are we going to get to watch
the fight tonight
and then all of a sudden you just come
out to the field and and you're all the
way down on the bottom my buddy's got
these crazy tickets like right front row
seats
looking all the way up it didn't even
look real
i felt like i was on the mandalorian
whether you're in the volume and they
filmed the [ __ ] and it's not really
there
um but it was real and uh
there was no lines waiting for food at
least where i was sitting
and um
and i had tom brady paul
and i had money on tom brady the
greatest quarterback
the nfl's ever seen
greatest quarterback since autogram
right there's one for you
i like it
you know you know me i don't deny that
you don't know anything about it
no i know tom brady tried to [ __ ] act
like you were paying attention in class
no tom brady and bill belichick with the
second coming of paul brown and otto
graham i want you to read up on that
um
so anyway
tom brady shows up the offense you know
i don't know they looked pretty good but
just the [ __ ] rams defense
yeah they they they
they really put a lot of pressure on
brady and then uh
tampa's secondary just could not cover
this [ __ ] white guy cooper cup
yeah this guy was like [ __ ] welker
and uh what's his face there [ __ ]
running all over the goddamn field they
just think
couldn't stop the guy and i was sitting
there going and i'm looking at the
scoreboard
and who do i see right out of the gate
before the game even starts joe burrow
[Laughter]
the lsu hero the heisman trophy winner
paul national championship smoked the
sticks
oh that was the best clemson
not only does he cover he beats the
pittsburgh steelers outright so i'm like
i'm [ __ ] one and up and i'm going
okay
all right worst case scenario i'm two
and two there's no way i lose these last
three games
[Laughter]
i've been watching football for 40 years
i know what i'm [ __ ] doing yeah i
look up
first two seconds to [ __ ]
dolphins are down 14 to nothing i got
the raiders given five
i don't want to i don't want to [ __ ]
talk about that game because that's the
game that [ __ ] me all right whatever
rams division rivalry they beat tampa
last year i should have seen that coming
maybe i don't know i figured tom was
going to get the [ __ ] revenge i lose
that game now i'm [ __ ] 1-1
i had seattle
i keep going with seattle every [ __ ]
week just because i won the first week
i'm an idiot i keep coming back not
realizing there's not going to be a
second date paul i keep knocking on the
door and she's still in the shower so i
lose that one
here's the one that [ __ ] me the
raiders
[Music]
creeping back
14 nothing then i look up it's 14 5.
it's 14 12. it's 19 14. it's 25 17.
and there's two minutes left and the
dolphins have the ball and i say to my
buddy i said they're gonna [ __ ] watch
this watch this they're gonna go into
the prevent defense
and give them four chances at the end
zone which is exactly what they did the
dolphins get it and get the [ __ ]
two-point conversion which actually
saved my bet because maybe the raiders
will score a touchdown in overtime
[ __ ] return a kick or something
nothing so i was 1-0 with joe burupal
and then i watched brady in the
buccaneers now i'm one and one
seattle [ __ ] doesn't cover i'm one
and two and then there are eight is [ __ ]
me
dude there has to be a name for when you
actually win a bet and then the previous
defense [ __ ] you oh i know we got to
figure that out we could have never been
on the other side of that bet that's why
you bet an underdog because you know
something you got the prevent defense
which may help you actually win the bet
that you really should have lost in the
end about that we could do that uh you
know have some of our clever creative
fans try to come up with the name of
when you got the bet in the bag and then
uh something happens with that but i got
to tell you you should be able to bet
that
you should be able to bet if they're
going to go into the [ __ ] prevent
yeah it's like when a guy goes up to the
crabs table and he plays the comedy
thinks somebody's going to uh crap out
what is that is that the pass bar
no i think it's i think it's the [ __ ]
line i think um but dude all i know is
when that guy comes over and bets
against the table it's such a buzz kill
but dude i'm at metlife stadium we're
playing a bad falcons team
saquon gets a touchdown okay
um daniel jones no fumbles no
interceptions he looks good two weeks in
a row i'm like we'll beat this falcons
team at home the day that they're
honoring eli manning by three points
we're up six we keep kicking field goals
we never take it in and then sure enough
penalty
two-drop interception what i mean it was
just and then and then i'm at a game
this is the second time it's happened to
me i'm at a game with four seconds left
and the opposing team kicks a field goal
zero's on the clock and we just walk out
with our heads down the giants i was
wrong about them even though they could
be two in one even though you should
have seen it coming though
i know you know why
because the whole time eli was with the
giants you were saying he didn't get the
respect he deserved
you were one of the few giant fans
that's true publicly that was that that
gave him his credit for winning two
super bowls right
so you should have known the day that
they were gonna honor him
that he get that last little bit of
disrespect
the giants were blowing it's always so
easy to see the storyline after you
[ __ ] lose
um all right so now we're still neck and
neck we're a game apart but now i like
i'm four and 12.
i'm four and eight
no you're not four and eight i'm four
and eight paul
oh well look i like this weekend i went
two and two
one and three
one and three yeah i'm four and eight
paul
you shouldn't even be talking to me paul
oh you went three and one
no i went two and two
oh that was your okay well i like this
week and i know you don't oh i like this
week i saw these i don't like i don't i
can't see it it's like i'm shooting pool
i can't see the angles anymore all right
so you get first pick this week bill i'm
shooting blind here paul
you get first pick this week
andrew the spreads you sent them right
to the yeah to the phone or today all
right
i'm gonna go with
all right should i go with my shocker
i'll save my shocker to the end paul yes
all right
i like
right out of the gate
i like the arizona cardinals
giving five to the los angeles rams i
feel like the rams are gonna be smelling
their own [ __ ] uh you know sniffing
their own [ __ ] thinking they don't smell
anything
right i think kyla murray is gonna be a
problem
i don't i don't even know paul i haven't
watched the second arizona car i am
literally i am shooting [ __ ] hoops in
the dark right now
all right i don't have a storyline as to
why i picked that
you just you're just going you're just
going i just like carla kyler murray i
like the cardinals
this mvp talk around this guy yeah you
think the rams are gonna you know you
know
they had a big data big [ __ ] win
they're sitting in the steam room they
got the towels around them they're
laughing they're grabbing ass [ __ ]
around joking
look at you joking they're doing it
they're whipping each other with that
um gotta tell you a little story eight
guys sitting around a bullpen figuring
out how the [ __ ] they got there
all right
all right saying they have the letdown
all right so
i i'm doing it again i can't believe i'm
doing this you better not take my bet no
no i can't believe i'm doing this but i
have to do it i have to do it
um it's just a it's just the personality
of my team and i'm taking the points the
new york football giants
are
are all in three
yes i know the new york football would
you like the nero and casino let her go
man
hold on they did they gave me a win this
year the new york football giants are
all in three two heartbreakers they're
getting eight points at the saints and i
don't fully trust jameis winston yet i
think jameis winston we don't know who
he is but that scooby-doo cast is going
to pull a mask off of him and it's going
to be somebody else i you the saints are
like a psycho girlfriend who the [ __ ]
are they they [ __ ] destroy
the goddamn packers they don't even show
up against the panthers
and then they beat the patriots i mean
that's nothing too crazy to be done but
it's just like i don't know what they
are
i've loved the giants on the road backs
against their wall getting eight i'm
taking my team eight points to start the
game that's my first pick
oh
all right i'm gonna make a versi pick
here because i'm afraid you're gonna
take this game
i don't know why paul
oh cause he keeps going crazy [ __ ]
points but i'm gonna i don't give a [ __ ]
because why not i know what he's doing
why not take the buffalo bills and just
be
17 to start the game the hapless
the hapless houston texans why not sit
there paul with my palms [ __ ]
sweating
i like excitement paul you know i'm
gonna [ __ ] give the houston texans 17
goddamn points at home against the
buffalo bills i believe in josh allen
i believe the sun
is gonna [ __ ] what are you saying
they're in buffalo they're in that's
what i'm saying they're in buffalo
that's not what i said
buffalo
so you you you're taking the bills to
cover 17 oh that's a mersey pick if i
ever seen one oh yeah paul i'm all over
the road here all right i don't know
what i'm doing anymore
oh do i take the cowboys i don't know
you know what i'm gonna do i'm gonna do
this one i thought you loved this week
paul i thought you were seeing clearly
you sound like me
i like the san francis my second pick
will be the san francisco 49ers
three-point favorites at home after a
heartbreaking gut-wrenching loss to the
last second to the packers okay
they're playing the seahawks and the
seahawks to me are like uh i don't think
the seahawks are
i don't know i'm taking the san
francisco 49ers bounce back game to just
cover three for myself all right paul i
got a [ __ ] stick
all right i'll bet you a [ __ ] cigar
on that one a side bet
because i like the seattle seahawks well
he could top the heartbreaker in
minnesota
i'll take the seahawks to [ __ ] beat
the 49ers what do you think about that
paul we're allowed to do that
clapping back
yeah we could do that
you can't do that yes
okay good i like it all i got left is my
shocker paul oh that's our first that's
our first head to head head to head
bald head the bald head
who's gonna lose their beard on this one
oh man all right dude so we wait how
many we have i get i have the giants and
i have the yeah i have two more we got
two more bill you got i got one left
paul
all right
um
all right this is where oh you picked
three paul this is your wait wait how is
this no i picked two no but paul you
held up three fingers and you said i got
two more i'm just calling that out
because it's going to be in the comment
section anyways all right
all right so i got the giants and the
49ers i got the giants and the 49ers and
my third pick for week number four
oh boy
oh where was it this doesn't sound easy
what no no no you had your warm-up suit
on before we were gonna start gambling
here you were just [ __ ] knocking them
down no i what i meant was i like a lot
of them i like a lot of these games oh
that's why you're making those noises i
thought you're making those noises like
i don't know i like that i like the
cowboy game i think i like i mean i'll
tell you what game i don't want to touch
is that denver broncos ravens game
that's a pick them that's a i don't like
that game at all and it's in denver
because either one of those teams can
just [ __ ] the bet or [ __ ] score a
bunch of points
denver just scored a bunch of points
against the jets but does that really
count
sorry jet fans jason i'm taking uh i'm
taking the los angeles chargers at home
monday night football beating the
raiders
oh i hate that game
i hate that game they just the chargers
just had that huge victory on the road
against the chiefs it's a division
rivalry game
the raiders almost blew it last week you
figured chucky's gonna go hard on him
this week paul
i know but that justin herbert
that's gonna be a great oh that's that's
the ga you know what i don't want any
money on that game because i want to sit
there and enjoy and not [ __ ] frighten
my family screaming at my tv
um
okay
here's my shocker of the week
oh and this might make me give get do
the unforgivable i have an o and four
game this week i mean
i can't believe the bills isn't your
shocker uh you got a better oh no no
paul oh this is why i got two kids under
the age of four i got so much [ __ ] going
i i i like the level you have to be
paying attention to be good like i
respect gamblers
okay i am that [ __ ]
who just grabs the [ __ ] program you
know with the [ __ ] horse races and
just starts picking him because he likes
the name i am gonna do something
unforgivable
oh boy i'm gonna bet against my new
england patriots
oh okay because i need a win here
i'm trying to pull freckles out of the
mud i'm gonna take the buccaneers
getting six and a half
um
[Music]
it's such a hard game
where belichick can coach rings around
bruce ahrens
but at the end of the day the guys
holding the football
is the greatest of all time versus a kid
who i think eventually is gonna be great
i believe in mac jones i believe in mac
jones but i just don't uh
i need to win paul
this is why they call you degenerate
gambler because at some point you end up
betting against your own team
well not like deny it and they don't put
you in the [ __ ] hall of fame for 30
years
the reason the reason why i like that
pick is i saw brady's face after that
loss and i was like that guy's going
back to new england after a loss oh it's
going to be a rough day for your pets
there i think
i know and i also think a lot of people
but the thing i don't like is i think a
lot of people think that and why is
vegas only seeing six and a half i don't
this is one of those trap games and you
know what paul i'm walking in both feet
i'm not even taking the stick to see if
it's gonna snap i'm [ __ ] taking a
little i'm just gonna jump right in it
[ __ ] is six and a half
and by the way i gotta give credit where
credit's due
our fine producer andrew themless he
said something last week and he was
right he said the bloodbath of the week
is going to be the cowboys and he was
right
andrew the silent
the silent man behind this podcast maybe
you guys ought to be listening to him
i swear to god paul if i go another one
and three week i i'm the next week i'm
gonna be on a [ __ ] unicycle with a
red nose on i gotta get a win here well
here's the deal dude you're a two-time
champ of this dude you're going for a
three-peat i'm glad you have to
understand i left the league
i'm jordan on the wizards right now
i came back a little fatter a little
slower i got two kids under the age of
four i'm making excuses look at me i'm
making excuses paul week
was this week four
week four week four i'm already making
we're not even out of september and i'm
i'm [ __ ] making excuses offense sex
the defense sucks we sucked
playoffs
i'm four and eight
uh all right
who do you got paul i love it uh i
that's it for me right oh you picked
your last one all right
easy like sunday morning right no i have
oh i have the uh i have the giants i
have the niners i have the chargers
chargers
oh look at this yeah you each have one
more you each have one more because no i
picked four i got the cardinals i got
seattle
i got the buccaneers and i got the bills
oh all right seattle that's i forgot i
thought that was got the giants he's got
the 49ers he's got the chargers
and
what do you think about that lions bears
game that's another tough one
i hate doing this
but i'm taking the i'm taking the
cowboys over the the panthers i don't
think the panthers are for real either i
don't believe in sam darnold everybody's
going everyone's on their dick because
they had a couple good games i'll tell
you something right now
dak prescott is my favorite cowboy
quarterback and i can't even believe i'm
saying that but that guy is for real
he's a good dude he says all the right
things he's a team player he went
through a bunch of [ __ ] he came back
they didn't give him that contract okay
he lost his brother rest his soul all
these things and he comes back with a
smile [ __ ] on him throwing up 400 yard
games i like dak prescott at home the
cowboys are flying as much as i hate to
say that to beat the uh the panthers
paul we're going head to head i got
sneaky pete he's going to sneak into the
[ __ ] 49ers stadium i like that head
get a victory i like that head to head
that's going to be a good one and that's
going to be a good one that's a division
right you might have to smoke a virtual
stick during that i'll i'm down i am
down oh some johnny blue
all right so there's our picks for the
week um you could be making a lot of
money if you do the exact opposite of
what i've been doing
that's actually at this point of
strategy
all right um here's here's an uh bet mgm
offer uh how's the software sound
everybody each week all customers have a
risk-free bet up to 25 bucks to use on a
first
touchdown scorer bet betting on the
first td scorer is a great great way to
make the first few drives more exciting
you just gotta opt in to the promotion
and pick a player to score the first td
is in his game
now first touchdown scorer markets
generally start at plus 600 for
favorites and go even higher for random
fullbacks or defensive touchdowns
imagine if you called a pick six or a
block punt that special teams guy
um
all right who do i think's gonna score
first i say brady
tom brady scores first on a 25-yard
naked bootleg we'll score the first td
in the buccaneers first
patriots this week if you bet 25 on
whoever you like and it hits you get uh
you get on your money and a nice payday
if you lose you get it refunded in a
free bet
uh we'll be keeping track of this all
season
yeah they should have they should have
stats on that paul
like who's uh who scored the most first
touchdowns for their team of the year
i'm sure vegas has uh bet mgm has
the line on that all right guys here's a
uh sunday night parlay special that we
got for you tom brady going into his old
stomping ground there i got a couple
things i think you tell me what you guys
think you can do three bets on one game
three bets on one game i got brady
throwing oh i like these three ready i
got brady throwing over two touchdowns
okay so he's gonna i got him throwing
over two touchdowns
i got gronkowski having under six
catches under six because i think
belichick's gonna take him out of the
game
and then my third is uh old mac jones is
gonna get a little cute and throw a pick
can we do those three
jesus paul why don't you just [ __ ]
give me the finger but i can't get mad
cause i bet against my own goddamn team
ah and that'll be a parlay so you gotta
hit all three you gotta hit them
can i put my thousand special
hey i put a thousand on that okay
so now does oh bill has to agree with
those bets or he could do his own
no no it's collectively this is
all right so bill if you don't like if
you don't like one of those things i
said you wanna we could switch it
do you like the brady over two touchdown
pass oh i have to i have to i my parlay
has to be the same [ __ ] game
you guys are both just gonna pick a
total of three bets to be a one parlay
it's the anything better cinematic
special
and you can pick any three bets that you
agree upon just for that game okay so to
be fair let's do one of mine so i say
brady over two touchdown passes now bill
you pick one for that game for that game
yeah
uh
i say mac jones throws a score
okay
is that is that something i can do
okay so mac jones throws a touchdown i
got brady throwing over two and then
what do you want to do for the third one
bill do you like i like your gronk under
six catches gronk under six catches he
took a nice shot last week his ribs are
hurt
yep belichick knows that belichick will
probably take him out of the game
so there you go mack jones throughout no
no he wouldn't take him out of the game
the other guy there the guy with the
kangoo
no i mean belichick will take gronk out
of the game oh with defense yeah dude
you can't take grunk out again i [ __ ]
hate this game this is like [ __ ]
betting against your own family you know
it's like a bad thanksgiving something
happened
this is it here don't forget if you
haven't signed up for bet mgm yet use
bonus code burr b-u-r-r and you'll be
able to place your first bet risk-free
up to a thousand dollars for week four
uh disclaimer here if you're 21 uh
disclaimer 21 plus years of age or older
to wager in arizona colorado district of
columbia
is that iowa they're using all
abbreviations here indiana
michigan missouri new jersey nevada
pennsylvania tennessee virginia west
virginia or wyoming only
new customers offer paid in free bets
visit
betmgm.com for terms conditioning
excludes michigan disassociated pers
disassociated persons please gamble
responsibly gambling problem call 1-800
next step az yeah people have fun with
this
wager with what you can afford don't be
a [ __ ] one 1-800-522-4700
in colorado d.c nevada wyoming and
virginia
1-800-2707-117 for confidential help in
michigan listen man i can't afford my
kids college education
uh 1-800 gambler in the indiana new
jersey pennsylvania and west virginia
1-800 bets off
that's off in iowa
call our text to tennessee red line
dude 800-889-9977 is like some new
medicine came out might cause diarrhea
nose bleeding call our text tennessee
redline
800-889-9789-777-9696 in missouri sports
betting is void in georgia hawaii ohio
and utah and other states were
prohibited i love you can't bet in ohio
but you can i mean utah but you can bet
you can marry like four [ __ ] broads
uh promotional offers not available in
nevada
would you rather bet on [ __ ] football
paul than bet on [ __ ] four women not
driving you up the [ __ ] wall all
right there you go and that is the uh
that's the thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast um
if you'd like to listen to some more of
my stupidity there'll be a little
musical interlude here some tasty music
picked out by the one and only andrew
themeless and then after that we have a
bonus half hour
of a thursday afternoon just before
friday monday morning podcast episode
from a couple years ago however he
figures it out uh that's it have a great
weekend you [ __ ]
and i'll i'll see you on monday
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday
september 30th
2013. what's going on how are you how's
it going did you have a nice weekend
i had a great weekend
do you like when somebody does that to
you they act like they want to know what
your weekend's like
so they can just talk about their
[ __ ] you know did you guys have a
nice weekend i did well let me tell you
all the awesome [ __ ] [ __ ] i did hang
on let me get my juice i got to get my
juice over here so i stay regular
oh [ __ ]
god damn it
you gotta be [ __ ] me i just spilt it
all over my [ __ ] drum kit what an
[ __ ]
ah jesus christ well you know what i had
a great weekend [ __ ] week's not
starting off by time this podcast is
over this place it's gonna be all sticky
really did it really have to [ __ ]
land there
juice gods i just dumped it over again
trying to set it down [ __ ] rug [ __ ]
all right hang on i gotta hit pause here
son of a [ __ ]
all right i'm back jesus christ
not once but twice you know what an
[ __ ] don't you isn't it [ __ ] worse
just owning [ __ ]
remember that when you didn't own
anything if you're young right now you
don't own something you [ __ ] spill
something you don't give a [ __ ]
yeah i'll get it later
i said i'll get it
now i got to be all concerned it's
[ __ ] hilarious to see this stuff i'm
drinking
spill it on the rug it looks like
god damn exorcist there's like nothing
left
christ this was gonna be my breakfast
um yeah i was in chicago this weekend
right so i ate like a pig
because that's what you do there you eat
like a [ __ ] pig and you grow a
mustache
even though nobody has a mustache out
there that i saw
um and they weren't really fat either
but i got to work at the uh the
beautiful uh chicago theater did two
shows out there
and um
i'm not gonna lie to you it was a little
overwhelming
that was uh
i gotta tell you it's like royal albert
hall is something that i would try and
compare it to i took a tour that one
time when i was out there in london for
you led zeppelin fans
fans of led zeppelin if you uh watch
that
uh that that [ __ ] video which to me
is a new one but it already came out ten
years ago
um that has all that concert footage
that one from 1970 that's where that is
filmed royal albert hall
and as far as the states go the closest
thing that we have to that would be the
chicago theater and i got to perform in
it and it was pretty awesome
and that's the end of that story i'm
still [ __ ] pissed about this
it was a great time so i want to thank
everybody for coming out there and you
know what sucks is i was so [ __ ]
overwhelmed i forgot i was gonna sing
when i came out there
you know i was gonna come out and be
like now this can only happen to a guy
like me boo boo boo and only happen in a
towel
so let me say to each of you
um
i could have done that i could have a
great [ __ ] time and i forgot because
i was too busy going like hey man i
gotta make sure i do a good job here man
this is like one of these big ones
um so anyways you probably ask yourself
hey bill
other than the usual
effeminate aspects of your personality
why is it that you're drinking juice for
breakfast
why is it um
i don't know why
because i ate like [ __ ] this weekend and
then uh
i don't know i ate something last week
that
my uh i don't know
i don't know my body treated it like a a
a
a terrorist cell it's like we need to
get these [ __ ] out of this country
immediately
and we don't care how many innocent
people we have to take with it all right
there's going to be some collateral
damage here okay everything in this
sector has to go but we didn't i said
get out of here right
for like four hours
last week
and it was such an effective like
my body basically committed genocide on
my my large intestine
there was nothing left
okay so
like three to the point like three days
later i don't get all graphic here three
days later
you know
they're basically other than i'll try to
say this as nicely as possible other
than watching a game that was really or
if i was tired there was no reason for
red face here to have to sit down if you
know what i mean for like three straight
days so now i think like oh wait a
minute so what happened so now have i
gone the other way
and now am i in uh
you know i went from [ __ ]
wide open to you know it's like
adjusting a carburetor it was too rich
and now now i'm not getting nothing
i got the choke pulled all the way out
here is that what the [ __ ] going on
here i got nowhere down there
so i'm freaking out and i'm like i've
been [ __ ] eating salads trying to you
know
so uh
i talked to this doctor and he goes and
the guy just broke the thing down he
goes all right so what happened i was
like well you know four days ago
it's so funny when you have to call a
doctor about that like how do you
eloquently say like yeah listen man i
haven't like [ __ ] in four days is that
is that a bad thing
and they just handle it like a champ all
right well what happened to you five
days ago i was uh [ __ ] my brains out
for like four hours
you know it was like the uh the dot-com
boom and everybody thought it was gonna
last forever and it just it the bubble
burst now it's nothing
so he's like well you're having any
abdominal pain uh do you have running a
fever i'm like nope nope i don't know
where he goes what have you been eating
i've got i've been eating salads he goes
all right well you probably don't want
to do that you don't need any more
roughage you want something else
and he said you need he actually said
syrup
say go out get yourself some pancakes
i'll go have a waffle or something like
that now listen you don't need to
[ __ ] tell me more than one time to go
out and get some [ __ ] pancakes
all right
with my sweet tooth okay i'm a little
light in the loafers over here when it
comes to food
i don't mind a little sugar in my tanks
like all right [ __ ] it so i'm in chicago
so i go out
and i go to ge i need i need some syrup
all right so i can't go down the front
desk and say hey listen i need some
syrup because uh
you know the oboe is not playing any
music anymore if you know what i mean
there
and um
i don't know if that even made sense
whatever i'm running out of metaphors
here they're not saying i'm having [ __ ]
so i don't know i just asked that [ __ ]
on my phone where the nearest
diner is she's like i found 47 locations
and then just you know carpet bombs the
screen
so i pick one that's like about point
three miles away and i'm going there
going maybe i'll just go in there and
get a shot of syrup
with an orange juice chaser
and i said now [ __ ] it i'll get i'll get
some french toast so anyways
i'm down near the chicago theater and
there's this weird part of the city
where there's like a city underneath the
city i don't get it so i'm walking over
towards it
and you know the phone isn't
three-dimensional so it's saying right
there but it's actually one level down
um it almost looked like uh blade runner
so
i'm sitting there of course cursing up a
storm around children and families of
course goes [ __ ] stupid ass [ __ ]
phone remember back in the [ __ ] day
you just ask somebody where the [ __ ]
the diner and they'd be like oh it's
there but it's downstairs so you got to
walk down here
suppose this [ __ ] just going oh it's
right over here make a left do this
you know siri doesn't care sorry
whatever [ __ ] issues give a [ __ ] if
you fall
if repelling is involved she doesn't
give a [ __ ]
all right that's not her fault
she's only as smart as the man that made
her
um
so anyways i find the stairs i'm
flipping on of course there's stairs
i go down the goddamn stairs so i walk
in
and i uh
i don't know i i order some french toast
and you would think you know it would be
the size the french toast would be the
size of uh sandwich bread
like it is in most places but this is
the midwest particularly
i say that right particularly
chicago
and i swear to god the french toast
shows up and it looks like you know
it'd be like if they decided how big
should that the french toast be and it'd
be like hey does anybody have one of
bubba smith's old [ __ ] cleats
let's just stick that in the batter and
trace it and that'll be uh how big the
[ __ ] bread should be can you trace
[ __ ] and batter well i guess you can't
if it's thick enough oh yeah let's trace
the bread around i'm just saying it was
[ __ ] huge and then they gave me two
slices his left and right foot with
powdered sugar
and i ordered an egg over easy on the
side because i like eggs and i got to
tell you something man
i went to this place called eggies
all right terrible [ __ ] name hey
let's go over the [ __ ] eggies doesn't
that sound like they're gonna be runny i
gotta tell you
the greatest egg over easy i ever had in
my life
the yolk was easy hey take it ease take
it easy the egg the yolk was [ __ ]
easy
but the the white part of the egg
was um the areola of the egg was [ __ ]
solid
i don't know how they did it i was like
maybe they had the heat real high
so right before the [ __ ] yolk gets
solid the white part gets all hard hard
and then they they slip it out i have no
idea but it was [ __ ] delicious and
i'm one of those guys i need a piece of
toast
if i'm gonna have an egg and i didn't
have toast and it was still delicious
still delicious and then i ate one of
the french toast things and i left the
other cleat to the uh french toast hall
of fame all right and wouldn't you know
wouldn't you know
three hours later
okay oh billy was making music out the
other end again and that's the end of my
giant [ __ ] story all right this is the
monday morning podcast everybody so
there's one for you if you ever [ __ ]
your [ __ ] brains out
and you know and you're still eating
well the next few days and you haven't
gone go get yourself a shot of syrup
with an orange juice chaser all right
and you're gonna be right as rain
okay
now granted after four days roadkill is
coming out of your is disgusting
um let me get a shot at you see oh
that's a good stuff
um
so anyways what else what else do i want
to talk about oh last night hey
breaking bad is over i don't be the 9
millionth person to talk about it but
jesus christ
wasn't that a great ending
i loved it i thought they uh
i thought they stuck the landing i'm not
gonna ruin for everybody because
everybody's well i'm only on season two
it's been out for six years
jesus i don't know you know what i've
never watched an episode of lost
have you seen lost no
i haven't
i haven't every time i put it on it's
that guy with the giant head and the
palamalu haircut and i can't figure out
what the [ __ ] going on and then the
captain from star trek is being evil
that's all i know that goes on on that
show so i have empathy so i'm not gonna
say anything but um
it was great
it was a great [ __ ] time
getting to be on that show and uh
that [ __ ] i mean there's no way to talk
about unless somebody saw the show why
the hell did i bring it up
anyways
so there you go the show's over and i am
unemployed as an actor again
and that is why that is why
no that's why
i would never stop doing stand-up even
if i didn't love it is because trying to
be a working actor
is that difficult that you can be on
something that great and then it just
[ __ ] ends
and it's over like stand up that doesn't
happen like if i was doing stand-up at
the level of breaking bad
there wouldn't be like okay and this is
your final stand-up gig and then it
drops off again i go right down
to ground zero and have to look for more
stand-up gigs and and like prove myself
all over again
i've often wondered like trying it
what's the hardest either
it's either trying to make it as far as
show business either trying to make it
as an actor
or trying to make it in a band
band's a rough one because
you got to split the money at least
three ways
you know unless you're in the uh
the black keys
or if you're in the white stripes then
you split it two ways but still you got
to get along with somebody else
all right and the more people you have
in your band the bigger chance that it's
just all going to go to [ __ ] look at
guns and roses
all right they had five people in the
band all right they start fighting
so a couple guys leave one guy gets
asked to leave another guy says hey i
don't like being dictated to so he takes
off
no steven no izzy
so they bring in [ __ ] matt sorum and
gilby clark
right so you got five guys and what do
they do then they bring in a keyboardist
dizzy they got in horn players all it is
is more people to be late to come
downstairs to get on the [ __ ] bus
and the whole thing implodes
everybody goes their separate ways
right
the next thing you know axel has
cornrows
okay now had that guy decided to just
tell jokes
just to do
stand-up you know which would have been
great
going to be great to see axel doing
stand-up every time he tells a joke that
gets an applause break he does that
little serpent dance to the side
i'm really trying to think of a joke
that ends with
you know where he could [ __ ]
i don't know
um that might be a nice sketch axel rose
is a stan if he was a stand-up comedian
he'd come on late he probably still [ __ ]
it up um not to have a little red on red
crime here
all right
you gotta hate when people do that you
gotta hate when it becomes cannibalism
here
i just completely lost my train of
thought oh i know what i was going to
say wait a minute how far into this are
we no 15 minutes in it's time to do a
couple of reads here people
all right it's time time to [ __ ] myself
out all right let's do a couple here all
right dollar shave club everybody there
are so many things in the world that
irritate me spilling juice
on my drum kit i don't have a drum kit
it's a little practice pad thing but i
got i do have the dw 5000 double kick
there
right when i finally got fed up 10 years
ago that i was never going to have a
foot as fast as john bonham i said to
hell with it
let me try to do this speed metal stuff
and that was just as hard
right so now i got this double pedal and
it's just sitting there like you
remember those hair metal bands in the
80s
where they they'd be just playing two
four basic phil rudd stuff but they
still the double bass drum kit so when
they did that uh
the drum solo they could just be running
underneath it and sound like you know
neil pearce whenever the [ __ ] when did
they become per your peer
neil pierce i don't know where it was
neil park the whole his whole [ __ ]
career and i don't know that irritates
me and it's not neil part anymore it's
near pier
um so those are the things that irritate
me hey but when so many things can
irritate you
why add raises to the list
you know it's time to stop milking your
razor blades people i know with brand
name razors you're used to paying
outrageous prices and exhausting those
razors until they start looking like a
rusty soda can well guess what it's time
to move on dollar shave club delivers
amazing quality blades to your door for
just a few bucks a month never think
about it again all right you're just
standing there bing-bong there's your
blades for a month they send you a pack
every month so you can change your
blades every week that's awesome man
that's what i why didn't i think of
doing this
i'd have to jump around like a monkey on
stage every damn week
anyways i love these guys and your face
is gonna love them too they also got a
new product called one wipe charlie's
it's a butt white for men and it's
classy
all right as opposed to that low-class
toilet plate paper just hanging around
you know one wife charlie get in get out
all right the harvey keitel the cleaner
if you will
of toilet paper any okay check out the
video for that sign up for your raises
today go to dollarshaveclub.com forward
slash burr that's
dollarshaveclub.comforwardslashburger or
go to billboard.com and click on the
dollar shave club banner i almost made
it through it um you know what a one
white charlie is that's basically
america slowly admitting that the french
got it right with the bidet
okay what we're doing over here with
toilet paper is ridiculous i'm telling
you if you ever get into a hotel and
there's a there's a bidet um make
yourself take a dozen just a big [ __ ]
podcast i'm telling you you got to use
one and you'll be like what the hell
have i been doing
you know
with my life although i'd maintain that
french people are still more stinky than
we are because they don't use deodorant
and who's kidding who when you have a
question in class you don't spread your
ass cheek all right i think everyone can
agree you raise your arm
all right
all right hula plus everybody
you've probably tried hulu.com now with
hulu plus you can watch your favorite
shows anytime anywhere hulu plus lets
you watch thousands of hit tv shows and
a selection of acclaimed movies on your
television or on the go with your
smartphone or tablet and it streams all
of this stuff in hd for the best viewing
experience possible with hulu plus you
can watch your favorite current tv shows
like saturday night live community
family guy
uh what else breaking bad you can get
all caught up you can probably watch
lost if you wanted to you can also check
out exclusive content including hulu
originals like the awesomes starring snl
seth meyers and moon boy starring chris
o'dowd from bridesmaids hulu plus also
offers a great selection of acclaimed
films for only 7.99 a month you can't
beat that you can stream as many tv
shows and movies as you want wherever
you want right now you can try hulu plus
free for two weeks when you go to
huluplus.com bill that's a special offer
for my listeners i love that line for my
listeners not yours mine make sure you
use huluplus.com
so you get the extended free trial
and then they'll know that we sent you
and they'll realize that this is working
go to hulupus.com bill now or click the
hulu plus banner on the podcast page at
billboard.com
all right that wasn't that nice wasn't
that nice and painless
all right here's what a [ __ ] i am
and we learned last week that i'm a real
[ __ ] all right i'm the real deal all
right if you tip me over you're going to
see the [ __ ] stamp of approval right on
my left butt cheek because i'm a lefty
sort of i'm also a righty
i'm all over the map god damn it this
[ __ ] juice is delicious kale celery
green apple
coriander the [ __ ] is that parsley and
lime what the hell's coriander
well that can't be a spice can't get any
juice out of a spice
that's the dandruff of food spices right
anybody ever put dandruff in an omelette
you know prisoner of war
i think that's disgusting um let's
[Laughter]
you use dandruff as powdered sugar
as you put it on like a wood shingle
pretending it was french toast
that's like some greatest generation
[ __ ] and they did it and then they never
talked about it
and then subconsciously took it out on
their kids
um and then you got the baby boom
generation bunch of [ __ ] cry babies
oh my god was there ever a bigger [ __ ]
generation than them
we don't want to go to war
man uh i'm just making up [ __ ] people
don't take this seriously oh you can
then i don't give a [ __ ]
uh
oh so i was talking about what a [ __ ] i
am
i'm driving down to get my juice today
my medicine
and um
you know someone was texting me and all
this type of [ __ ]
and i'm trying not to text while i drive
but i do
i text them back when i can't do your
podcast today i'll do it next week doing
kevin farley's
podcast next week yet another person on
the all things comedy network
um
so
by the way i'll be on that next week
so anyways i'm driving over to the juice
bar and um
i pull in i get the juice throw the bag
come back out
and there's like nobody there i got a
great parking spot and all i want to do
is just whip around do a u-turn right
like on adam 12. every time they got a
call they would never go in the right
direction they always had turn around
right
and you just can't it's like [ __ ] out
here in la i swear to god it's like the
goddamn truman show
it says just know what the [ __ ] you're
gonna do so i go to do it and out of
nowhere this [ __ ] jerk off he just
appears
right right out of the [ __ ] air
and not only does he block me from doing
it like i'm just starting to pull out a
little bit he pulls into the parking
spot right in front of me front end
first it almost takes off my front end
you know like when you almost get into
an accident even when you're wrong
because i was wrong so i should have
looked he had the right away but you get
mad
like i flipped out i just because i got
scared like oh my god i'm going to rip
off the front of my car and then it
didn't happen i was like jesus christ
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you start flipping out and then and as
you're yelling at the guy
inside your car there's that voice in
the back of your head going you were
wrong
you were the wrong one
that happened to me like three times
just [ __ ] jerk off in front of me i
go around the block
and he's doing that driving where you
know they're texting
you know sort of creeping along
and then and then all of a sudden i know
we're going real fast all of a sudden
they're a good driver and then they
completely suck at driving then it's
like they're sober they're drunk they're
sober they're drunk that is [ __ ]
classic texting while driving and i pull
up alongside of the guy look at him sure
enough he's looking down as he's driving
and i go look at this [ __ ] idiot
texting while driving
and literally i had been doing it a half
mile earlier probably making the same
person do that i'm such a [ __ ]
hypocritical
[ __ ] you know at least i guess maybe i
can hear who the hell is texting me
oh jesus christ
these people know i spilled juice all
over my rug and i don't have time for
text
um
anyway so i don't know if i even said it
i want to thank everybody who came out
to uh
the chicago theater this weekend that
that was an unbelievable
unbelievable experience and i definitely
took a lot of photos took a lot of video
because that's one of those things where
you're doing it and you're like uh am i
ever gonna get to do this again
it was insane
um and if you ever get a chance to go to
chicago here's a great there's a great
little weekend trip
for those of you who don't live there in
chicago is basically i know it's a
little more east coast but essentially
it's it's no more than a four-hour
flight for anybody in the lower 48 here
um if your favorite band is playing
there that would be a great weekend
go in there
see your favorite band
at the chicago theater and then hang out
and eat their awesome heart attack food
uh which i didn't even get a chance to
do
because of uh the earlier story and also
i flew in that day oh you know what the
[ __ ]
i should have taken the weekend there
but i'm too busy i'm going right back up
this weekend um
the el paso gig people
is happening
trying to happen again for the third
[ __ ] time i've already lost two fans
for life because of this gig
but i am determined
i am determined
that i'm gonna make this thing happen
and uh the gig is on wednesday
and uh last time it was gonna be paul
verzi
who was gonna open for me uh he's busy
this time around i'm bringing uh
the rose bowl tailgate king
all right
the sinatra
of our rose boat tailgate
uh joe bartnick
is coming out and uh
this guy is one of my favorite people
and one of the funniest people i've ever
met in my life he's funny when he's
trying to be funny and he's funny even
when he's not
trying to be funny he's a total
[ __ ] original
really just lives by his own code he's
just uh
he's [ __ ] awesome man he's a
throwback
throwback to a different era
um so he's going to be coming out there
i'm actually believe it or not i'm going
to drive out there that's how beautiful
the drive from el paso to san antonio
was i got to see the rest of this
i got gotta see the rest of the
southwest so i'm driving la to el paso
it's like a 12 hour drive which that's
not that's not bad
you know
you just break it up break it up but um
i'm timing it where i'm going to be out
in the desert as the sun's going down um
look at me drinking juice trying to see
a sunset right am i evolving as a man or
am i uh
am i gonna start going on stage like
duran duran wearing a little bit of
makeup that wouldn't be bad right a
little eyeliner
what would you guys do if i went that
direction
and all my all my i stopped talking outs
about sports i went that direction
and then all of a sudden everybody was
saying that i was ripping off eddie
izzard
there's a left turn
you know or brian adams
after you know he came out he was
wearing the jean jacket looking like the
guy that might have some weed and then
all of a sudden he decided i can't you
know he became more poppy
everything you do everything i do i do
it for you that's one of the saddest
[ __ ] songs ever
just completely lost in a relationship
you've completely you know you know his
friends hey should we call up brian ah
and uh you know well once ever since he
met julie you know
jesus i never thought it would happen to
him
remember that we used to [ __ ] you
know
we should get [ __ ] up in the barn
right
whatever the [ __ ] they did in that video
and then somewhere along the line he
spiked up his hair and put on some
eyeliner
jesus christ you know when he was making
that video he was just saying to his
manager like dude this is either the
beginning or the end
uh this better [ __ ] work and the
manager is probably like nah that's a
great thing it's a great [ __ ] thing
and then when it's [ __ ] the bed his
manager can't be found
where the hell is he all right let's
talk nfl football uh unfortunately i
didn't really see any this week i
i was flying back from uh
chicago when all uh the early games were
on
and then um
my patriots were late night and i didn't
get a chance to see that because this is
what i did i came home
and i got caught up on the scores
just in time i haven't seen the
highlights to see seattle's big comeback
or the texans big choke depending on
which side of the ball you're on
um i know the jets lost
uh all i saw was the first quarter and a
half of the patriots and um
i'm happy
that we were able to get past the
falcons because i feel like that's the
first quality team that we've played
but um
i don't know i already saw somebody was
trying to say that we're the only ones
going to legitimately challenge the
broncos and i don't think it's going to
be much
i don't know you never know when
belichick is involved
what scheme he can come up with and god
knows you can frustrate peyton manning
but they look [ __ ]
amazing
so uh i wish that the broncos would just
play seattle already because i want to
see
you know two things i want to see
seattle on the road against a team that
good because verzi's been telling me
they're not good on the road he almost
called it with the texans they didn't
[ __ ] choke
um i saw the picture on nfl.com it's
hilarious
his uh
sherman the beast there running the ball
back and you get to see
you get to see pete carroll p carol is
in full like
i can't tell if he just finished going
whoo
or if he's about ready to say it
um
but they uh they're looking like [ __ ]
world beaters up there i got oh by the
way i'm going to be up in seattle this
week and uh it's going to be [ __ ]
hilarious because i'm playing this
awesome venue plus all the morning radio
shows up there i think for the most part
they they played when i was singing we
are the loudest so there's a lot of
pissed off
um
12th man people out there so i don't
know we're gonna see we'll see what the
[ __ ] happens
i don't give a [ __ ] either way to be
honest with you
um
if something goes down when i'm up there
that's it's a very easy city to make fun
of so i think i can do more than 12
minutes
um but i'm hoping it's not gonna be you
know what is annoying about all those
morning radio shows is all they did was
like now they'll just edit right there
they won't have this part they left out
the whole part where i said i thought
that seattle was going to go to the
super bowl and they looked like the team
to beat
um
they left that they left out where i you
know
didn't give pete carroll [ __ ] for what
the [ __ ] he did at usc because everybody
does it by the way people who are still
doing that spy gate [ __ ] bringing up uh
you know bringing up belichick and that
type of thing like they always love to
do with the patriots i was watching the
lsu game unfortunately they lost
um great game great [ __ ] game uh
against georgia
and uh dude by the way who the [ __ ] did
georgia piss off
with their september schedule
jesus christ clemson lsu and there was
somebody else highly ranked that they
played i forget who
um
but anyways in the middle of the game
like
both coaches when they're talking
they're covering their mouths they're
covering their lips as they're talking
like so like they're in casino
and the announcers even go well they
must have got word or something going on
this everybody [ __ ] does it
so [ __ ] one of those seattle fans was
giving me [ __ ] i was talking you know
because i made fun of their team was
sitting there talking about you know
belichick being a cheater it's like dude
did you see what [ __ ]
pete carroll did down at usc
what the [ __ ] he was doing i don't give
him grief about it because everybody was
doing it but i mean come on
right as the the guillotine was that was
coming down he [ __ ] slips out of town
left all those kids high and dry with
their scholarships and some no-name
coach
who i think just got fired
um how psyched to the tennessee fans
watching the fact that it didn't work
out out there
that's another shout out to knoxville
jesus i'm gonna go there one day and
they're gonna give me the key to this
city
i wonder what it looks like you know am
i gonna do a redneck joke here i don't
have one let's plow ahead here everybody
um so by the way so i didn't watch much
football because uh versey kept telling
me how uh amazing
the lawrence taylor uh documentary was
and uh directed by the one and only pete
radovich who's the guy who got me on
inside the nfl so congratulations to him
because i've heard nothing but rave
reviews and i sat down and watched it
and it was [ __ ]
it was awesome
it was really awesome and you know what
i don't know if it was the way it was
edited but there was a lot of [ __ ] that
the media was doing to lt when he was uh
under the influence that was bug you
know what really bothers me is when
somebody famous gets arrested and then
the cops have to have a press conference
why do they have to have a press
conference why do they have to come out
there with like 20 microphones and
everybody taking pictures and the stupid
police chief comes out at approximately
uh 1 28 in the morning we arrested uh
barbara streisand
outside of a uh symphony hall
with what we believe was allegedly some
uh
crack cocaine
um
why can't they just arrest them
why do they why do they have to have a
[ __ ] press conference why do they
gotta go out there and [ __ ] themselves
out go into hair and makeup get some
powder put on their face right slick
back their cop hair and walk out there
practice me [ __ ] 6 28 shut the [ __ ]
up
you know
and then all the media has to sit there
while lt was going through a [ __ ] is
sitting there acting like they're
shaking their head when they're totally
exploiting the guy for ratings now
granted lt put himself out there like
that to have it done
but um
i don't know
and i have to tell you something uh in
the documentary
there's something that lt's first wife
does
that is uh one of the things that i find
most terrifying
about
uh women
and uh
i don't want to ruin it for you
but she says lt cries at his daughter's
wedding
and she comments on his crying
and then they cut to the funeral and she
reaches over and puts her hand on his
forearm to comfort him
after what she had just said is one of
those [ __ ] things that sends chills
down my spine
but definitely check it out
it's uh
it's [ __ ] amazing and
if anybody knows just one of the cigars
that lt is smoking he looks like he
smokes the greatest cigars
of all they have two bands on them
all right so to me in my ignorance
that's like the greatest cigar ever it's
so good it had to have a second band on
it
um
i don't know that's what i got that's
all i got out of it that if i ever
become a parent i got to be there for my
kids and secondly i got to figure out
where lt's getting his cigars but
definitely check that out if you get a
chance and congratulations once again to
pete radovich for doing an unbelievable
job that's one of those ones that
immediately after i watched it when i
hit stop and it said if i wanted to
erase it or not
i hit save
and you know you have that save
indefinitely that's one of those ones
i'm going to keep going back to because
it was uh
it was tremendous all right
where are we are we going to get into
the letters at this point are we we at
that time 34 minutes in hey how come you
can't protest without getting tear gas
shot at you
all around the world
you know they act like you you know we
want to hear from our people
and you go out there and you're just
sitting out there all you're doing is
you got signs and you're chanting
and then the cops come down there and
they start pushing people around and
they throw [ __ ] tear gas
i don't understand why why can't you do
that why aren't you allowed to protest
look i understand if you go down there
and you start breaking windows and that
type of [ __ ]
uh but i i actually believe and i know
you guys are gonna think that i'm
paranoid if i was in power i would just
say hey hey how old you son
yeah send him out there and have him
throw a rock through a window so we can
look justified when we get rid of these
[ __ ] people out here
um
adam sorry i'm going back down the
[ __ ] rat hole again
somebody sent me a great rant that this
guy went on on a news program
and he was talking about the bankers
because i can't even watch news right
now with our government might shut down
in a couple of days but this guy
was basically going off saying all that
banker [ __ ]
that i was trying to say a few years ago
and i started watching those videos and
everybody was saying oh you these are
[ __ ]
fat guys living in their mother's
basements who uh they don't have any
lives and you just you know you're
drinking the kool-aid and all this [ __ ]
now look a lot of that stuff we never
landed on the moon i'll give you all
that [ __ ]
okay maybe all of that stuff 911 is an
inside job i'm not talking about any of
that [ __ ] crap but that banker [ __ ]
i'm telling you
that banker [ __ ] is dead on
dead [ __ ] on it's not the left it's
not the right
it's those [ __ ] right in the middle
with money on both sides of the ball
it's those guys
and um i have to tell you dude the fact
that the president only makes 400 grand
a year
and that just the way they frame it like
oh he's a public servant
it's the biggest crock of [ __ ] out there
the only person who would take that job
you'd have to be the biggest [ __ ] yes
man on the planet just to get there
you who the [ __ ] would run for a job
where it cost 100 million to get it so
you can make 400 grand a year
that isn't a red flag to anybody
then you get to go around giving
speeches a million dollars a whack like
that isn't your kickback for [ __ ]
pushing through whatever they wanted i
just think it's it's so beyond corrupt
um
and i used to think [ __ ] like i can't
believe we're letting these pencil
pushing banking
[ __ ] push us around but it's not them
it's the fact that people will do
anything for money so when you have that
kind of money you can hire psychos
and uh you know
i don't know you get that you get that
lincoln town car ride
the convertible in dallas all right
i spoke about it vaguely but you know
what i'm saying all right let's let's uh
let's move on okay now i mentioned that
i was going to go to naples and i don't
think i might as well have said that i
was going to go to atlantic city
all right or downtown detroit
everybody is [ __ ] all over naples
all right here's one that sums it up uh
everyone says naples is the worst words
used to describe naples [ __ ] trash hole
smell like smells like wet rats great if
you're into visiting the worst part of
any place
if you do go to naples only use it as a
jumping off point to capri
and pompeii
yeah i mean
that's what everybody has been telling
me everybody's saying look if you're
going to italy for the first time go to
rome
all right you're going there in december
so we won't be a big time touristy thing
but there will be tourists use that as a
jump off point go to florence i mean i
heard venice i mean the [ __ ] place is
underwater i heard that you know
i heard that that was kind of smelly
i don't know but you know what you guys
you talked me out of naples
you talked me out of it now watch now
here comes the other side don't listen
to those [ __ ] [ __ ]
whatever i'm going to italy how could it
possibly suck
smash cut
all right refugee
here we go refugee oh the lovely nia
everybody
need you know i spilt my juice all over
the [ __ ] place
the green juice to cleo get off the bed
look at her nose
our [ __ ] dog tried to get out of the
goddamn
cage again because the wind was blowing
bumped up scratched up her friggin nose
pit bulls i swear to god in here once
they get their mind on doing something
they're just going to do it right
they're brutal i don't know you're
coming down go plug in another
microphone
let's do the
uh let's do the thing here all right
all right do you have the ability to uh
do you have the ability to uh listen
while uh while i are while you plug that
thing in
all right all women think that they can
multitask it's the funniest [ __ ]
thing ever i can you can't
even you can't nia
well look everybody could do two things
at once
what the [ __ ] you talking to drums i can
do four things at once what are you
doing that's the wrong one
huh
listen scientific studies have shown
that people studies have shown one of my
favorite quotes of all time i actually
saw this on tv that
that basically
if you do two things at once
they both suffer because you don't have
a hundred percent focus
you know what i mean
does that make sense to you
yes it does
okay
yeah you are right
all right here we go all right hey bill
this is a refugee
hey
hey bill i got to know you when i was a
refugee in turkey
i escaped from prison what yeah i don't
know i
listen everybody everybody's got the
internet man you're the number one
podcast from for refugees refugees in
turkey yeah this sounds like the
beginning of a movie i don't know if i'm
going to believe this let me let's let's
see if this is true i got to know you
when i was a refugee in turkey i escaped
from a prison sentence for my political
activities in the university in iran
jesus christ dude
somebody's got to get this guy in touch
with ben affleck this sounds like a
movie and he can play him yeah
[Music]
i'm telling him i'm tony
ben no shane um hi i'm tony mendez
that was [ __ ] hilarious
then when you saw the real tony mendez
and he looked like freddie fender that
was one of the funniest
i mean i liked i liked argo argo was
great but the end of that movie no shade
ben affleck but the whole the whole
movie is going up tony mendez are you
if anything would give that guy away
would be his last [ __ ] name listen
man you need to go get more of a tan or
grow a [ __ ] mustache both looked at
each other when we said when he said
that we're like
no i was actually sitting there in the
movie going wait a minute is that
italian
maybe
mendes mendes
i go a before that makes it italian um
oh and then the end when they everybody
looked like the person but then when
they showed ben affleck and then they
cut to tony mendez it was this [ __ ]
guy
it was really far away
it was profile and it was completely
shadow oh yeah everybody else was a
close-up his it was it was a full bloody
shot with another white guy in there
that he was shaking hands with it you're
like oh maybe ben's playing the white
guy oh my god he's tony mendez well
right there it just shows you what an
incredible actor he is
um he played tony mendez all right hi
bill i was a refugee when i was in
turkey i escaped from a prison sentence
for my political activities in the
university and i ran
since i was a kid i always loved comedy
isn't this [ __ ] great this is why i
love i love this [ __ ] look at this this
this is this is billy redface coming out
iran
uh there were only two funny magazines
in iran
and i had all their issues since the
beginning yeah this is how lucky we are
well okay yeah they had mad magazine
iran
and national lampoons
don't make fun of the ayatollah vacation
um i didn't know stand-up comedy existed
until i was 25.
unreal being funny wasn't a good thing
uh in turkey i had 30 months
i guess he had a sentence and i watched
everything from prior and cosby and
carlin to hicks to chappelle he was in
prison and was able to get to the
internet to watch all these like
uh i don't know yeah i guess well do
people make hang gliders in prison out
of dental floss and bed sheets they
can't get the [ __ ] internet
uh what's prison so no you can't get the
internet listen which i was actually
watching in iran and i saw you there
uh the first time as well
as a detective she puts her tits in my
hand god that was funny louis ck patrice
sam kinnison and you and everything in
between i have listened to you guys this
is [ __ ] great if this is true i
listen to you guys just talking about
comedians on radios or podcasts and i
looked them up i saw every episode of
tough crowd out of all the comedians
i've seen you're in my top five
ah look at this
you prior cosby louis ck he's partial
the gingers and dave chappelle that's
what he likes he likes black guys and
gingers i like this guy
i started
jesus i'll try to keep it on this side
of the road okay
i started writing in turkey uh my friend
told me my friend told me to i did and
it was well received i started writing
in english and i'm building courage to
perform this is [ __ ] great
uh i just want to tell you how much i
appreciate those nights when i was
sitting alone in turkey and i didn't
speak its language and i would watch one
of your standups and forget everything
and laugh and laugh i found out today
that that you are in toronto i've been
here four months now i'll try to find
tickets how did i miss this email if the
show hasn't finished yet i will see you
live sir i promise thanks again bill and
say hi to your nia that's great well i'm
gonna tour yeah i'm gonna tour uh canada
in march i'll come through all of these
what if this is all just a big
scam
to get him to somehow i don't know throw
a pie in my face and do something to me
come up with that water that squirts in
your face where in canada are you going
in march
whereabouts um
i don't know i'm going to go to all the
hockey cities and i'll maybe i'll add a
couple others are you going to be in
montreal yeah why don't you just get
down to it where you want to go
because you think you exactly and you
think i don't know what you're doing
that's why do you see what just happened
there
this is like two fighters that know each
other at this point i know what you do
and you know what i do
the second you said
the second you said why are you going to
canada i'm like well say why i said
where are we going where are you going
to canada i knew you liked to
misinterpret everything as some sort of
like see what she's doing right now
she's filibustering i'm not filming
filibustering i'm always looking for the
you know the old kick in the balls and
that's not what this is i was asking
where you're going in canada if you're
going into montreal i would why are you
smiling at me i would want to go too
but i was gonna get to it
you're done
yes see you just let her laying on the
ropes all right so the second you said
when are you going to canada
i knew
wait no where are you going in canada i
knew i'm like she loves montreal she
wants to go so what i did to slip that
punch is i said i'm going to all the
hockey cities because i know you don't
watch sports so then you got to be so
then you had to show your hand i called
you bluff and you're like uh yeah there
you go to montreal
but why even do that if you know that
then just say oh i'm i i am going to
montreal or i am not
you're doing this i don't know because
because it because it it because it's
bug what about yeah i'm going there to
work i'm packing my hard hat and my mic
stand okay it's your heart and your mind
yeah you don't think it's work do you
of course i think you don't respect me
you don't respect what i do just say
jesus
oh oh you know what somebody sent a
great [ __ ] video
this week of some goddamn movie
with this guy he just said this is some
scene he just says oh jesus like 15
times in a row i got to show you this
where it is
where it is where it is what it is
[ __ ] all right here it is listen
to this guy
oh jesus yeah oh jesus
jesus
oh [ __ ] jesus
where is that from
uh it says dylan moran
okay
i gotta tell you movie yeah and my
agent's gonna get an ear load of [ __ ]
that i didn't read for that part i would
have killed that
oh jesus
thank you oh jesus that's great that's
great phil next oh [ __ ] jesus
he was good but he was doing something
weird with his voice
all right dui
uh oh wait i got to read the other uh
the advertisers here all right bear with
me here bear with me bear with me uh
okay e-voice
all right everybody if you're an
entrepreneur and a customer calls do you
want to seem like you're in a high-rise
window view fancy-pants office how do
you want them to know that you're just
sitting there in your underwears
uh with e-voice you can create the
appearance of an entire building sales
customer sport tech support you name it
they'll think you got it give your
customers the royal treatment with
e-voice e-voice will forward your
business calls to your home mobile or
any number you choose whenever wherever
you are evoice will find you i know i
always my brain goes too far ahead in
the sentence because you can't do two
things at once
which is what reading and doing it out
loud yeah no i i can't i can't do two
things at once
i can't multitask something suffers
and neither can you yes i can are you
done like what no i'm not all right well
stop heckling me
don't have time to take a call
it's routed to your voicemail and you
can read it at your conveniences in
email e-voice not only gives you the
edge over your competitors
it takes the edge away from the big
companies what they have over you right
now that's the biggest point right there
okay you get to act like a big shot and
now you can try e-voice for free for 30
days go to evoice.com
or go just go to the podcast page at
billboard.com and click on the e-voice
banner
all right last but certainly not least
uh legalzoom you know a lot of pride
comes along with starting your dream
business but think about the stress you
feel if you don't take the right steps
to legally protect your business and
personal assets from the beginning why
because people are so happy so you know
what that's why i recommend
legalzoom.com during the past 12 years
over a million business owners have
trusted legalzoom to help start their
own businesses legalzoom will save you a
lot of time and a pile of money on
startup costs plus they'll provide
solutions to help you run a successful
business legalzoom can provide self-help
services at your specific directions or
correct you uh
or connect you with an attorney but they
are not a law firm just go to
legalzoom.com today to see what's right
for you form an llc get a dba
incorporate or form a non-profit all
starting at just 99
plus you'll save even more when you
enter bur in the referral box at
checkout that's legalzoom.com promo code
bur one more time legalzoom.com
promo code burr
all right that wasn't bad i only screwed
it up once
um
i know i'm the worst all right dui
hey bill
hey billy um
want to start up the same way you know i
love staying up all right i'm 23 year
old guy
from houston and on september 22nd i was
arrested for the first time for a dwi
it's funny he has dui driving under
influence driving while intoxicated in
the thing all right
is it the same it is it's just
it's called the dewey dude dude he got a
[ __ ] day
um
i took my eyes off the road and
rear-ended two vehicles at a light oops
jesus he split the difference vehicles
well either he hit one and it smashed
into the other or they were both side by
side maybe he was so drunk he thought he
could fit between the two of them
he said no one was seriously injured but
the wreck brought an ambulance and
several squad cars to the scene they
arrested me and i blew so needless to
say i'm in a pickle
the lawyer i have however is good
friends with the judge and the court he
asked for the state's evidence against
me and there's a chance we can beat it
in the meantime the court has me blowing
into a breath alcohol device
deal type of thing with the with cameras
to ensure i'm not drinking and also a
piss test every court date
uh this is fine with me because jail
sucked court sucks and cops and the
government workers are extremely rude
oh jesus dude yeah who was driving drunk
you killed somebody and they're real
let's see what he says
because of all of this
and being out on bond i'm having to keep
my nose extra clean have to lay really
low and just exist it's a bummer and
also hard not to think about drinking
also i gotta move out of my folks house
by november 1st they're not kicking me
out or anything they're being very
supportive it's just a date i set for
myself before any of this happened the
fees and the lawyers are going to give
me some financial woes and it will be
tough any advice you can give me
uh will be much appreciated thanks bill
well i mean you should be happy you
didn't [ __ ] kill somebody and um you
know if you weren't
driving under the influence you wouldn't
have to run into all these rude
government workers so
what is the advice that you're looking
for here you want somehow like hang in
there buddy
yeah um i i would go out of your goddamn
parents house you loser
sorry i got no sympathy all right nia
none mia bringing the hammer down uh
rude jail sucks
oh does it
[Laughter]
all right well it's hard for me to come
down on this guy because uh all the [ __ ]
i've done and uh i've also you know
[ __ ] you know i i got arrested for
that [ __ ] a long time ago i i just you
know what i did i took my medicine and
you know what i remember when i went in
and i was finally getting my license
back the state trooper went to hand it
to me and right as i went to grab it he
pulled it back really quick he goes wait
a minute was it 90 days or 45 i only got
45 that's how long ago it was
and i was like he was 45
and then he handed it back to me he gave
me that last little heart attack thing
and i was thinking when i was younger he
was a dick he was actually doing me a
favor let me know like you know this is
how simple it is
and um
and it was it was an absolute nightmare
even at that just having my toe
dipped into the legal system did they
put you in a like a holding cell or
whatever you got arrested how long were
you there for i don't remember i was
just psyched i could lay down were there
other people in there
no
oh okay no no no i was fortunate got
arrested in a small town but i mean if i
uh if you got arrested like in boston
boston yeah i would have gone i they
probably would have put me in county and
that would have sucked
that would have sucked because then
you're in there with everybody that's
getting arraigned for everything from
eating somebody's head
to uh me drinking and driving and you
think if i look like ron howard now
i look like ron howard the director now
but back then
i look like ron howard living at home
with mr and mrs cunningham
so that would have been uh you were
richie you were opie when you were
little then you were richie and i was
richie
now ron howard oscar-winning director
yeah
that's a cruel joke speaking of which we
got to see sandy's movie
sandy sandra bullock yeah okay
sandy she lives next door
no that one looks good and so does the
the ron howard one
um
what was i gonna say uh yeah so dude you
know what you did it and um
look i it was actually a great thing
when i g when i got arrested and i had
to go through drunk school and all that
and the mothers against drunk drinking
and driving and all this information and
all the stuff that they show you and i
had to do community service i they did
it at this hospital and i was wheeling
all these people down to physical
therapy and uh some were born that way
one got hit by a drunk driver
so i mean it definitely uh it hit home
and i was a knucklehead like this guy
kind of feeling sorry for myself rather
than uh thinking about what could have
happened and how dude this is this is my
thing you got off easy
you really got off easy and uh having to
stay sober is actually a great [ __ ]
thing
it's a great thing and um to kind of you
know take your foot off the gas pedal
there and
kind of regroup
as far as like when you can move out it
all depends on what this whole thing's
going to cost you but uh this all
happened because of your actions and you
are guilty
you blew in the thing and you were drunk
so you got to take your [ __ ] medicine
what are you going to do so i would i
would just take it on the chin be a
[ __ ] man
and if that makes you you have to move
out december 1st or january 1st then
that's what you have to do and uh
it's a great way to because it seems to
me like you like to party quite a bit
that you're staying sober for a few days
if that's bugging you like that that
should kind of tell you something kind
of like me with the cigars now
all right you know where i all of a
sudden want one every night what did he
say about having
some in judge lawyer what did he say
yeah that he could possibly get out of
it and he could fight it and get out of
it so he's got all these people sort of
cushioning him along the way like oh my
parents aren't kicking me out they're
being very supportive and he's got this
person that could possibly get him out
because they haven't ended with a judge
so everybody's being nice to you which
is why you then look at the government
going these guys are being rude to me
he's a kid all right these guys the
spoiled brat is what he is hey well look
nobody nobody can hear your point when
you come at somebody like that i gotta
[ __ ] send you a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
like no one here that's that's how
that's political debate in this country
right now oh i'm sorry should i be
wrapping my arms around him like
everybody else in his life and telling
him did i wrap my arms around hurry it's
okay we'll figure it out you don't have
to move out just yet don't worry we we
got it in with this judge all right
that's a decent point but was i wrapping
my arms around him yeah but you're
coming at me saying nobody hears you
when you come out you know like that
like i'm somehow listen well later on
the podcast me don't have you back up
you're not all defensive maybe you can
hear what it is that i'm trying to say
to you wow yeah really that's called
maturity all right
screw you
oh i won that one you did you won
nothing it was just a battle it wasn't a
war
wasn't the war you're looking extra cute
today by the way
don't even try it i'm not i'm just
saying
get a nice smile
all right oh you guys are you guys are
this is my a game by the way
uh advice
[Music]
for an atheist in love with christian
fundamentalists oh i love it
um
as an atheist
dating a christian fundamentalist jesus
christ you thought opposites attract
over here nene
complete with a purity ring
an anal retentive folks how funny is it
to have purity ring and anal that
quickly wait
i cannot say it initially
i cannot say it initially seemed
promising even con even considered
living not leaving that's the worst
i'm the worst
illiterate jackass i know but you know
what this does this gives this gives my
listeners hope i really hope everybody
listens who just thinks that this
[ __ ] [ __ ]
can play the chicago theater i i can't
[ __ ] do it too
um
as i throw each one of you
a kiss
that was funny when i was trying to sing
you that song and i said as i blow each
one of you i was gonna say blow each one
of you kiss and he pauses as i blow each
one of you and you look at me like what
the [ __ ] are you singing
this is my kind of email all right um
but this this girl
is really she's really something else
um you know this is probably the sexist
in me
that i initially thought that it was a
guy with the purity ring and i as a
christian fundamentalist with the purity
ring as a guy for some reason i think
that that's creepier
than a woman actually if she has a
purity ring
like i think that that's not as creepy
because as a guy
you know when you fall in love with the
woman you want one that's been just on
the least and that's really what it
comes down to
i don't want somebody else's [ __ ] sweat
on her chest cavity
you know i'm just not yeah
we're very visual animals okay um
there goes the a game right out the
[ __ ] window all right but this girl
is really something else short of sex
she pushes boundaries she demands that
she pay for half of our dates
works her ass off too in a year of
knowing her she is never freaked out
and the crazy thing
um i can basically go m.i.a for two
weeks and it's like nothing happened
everything just continues because she's
banging somebody else
i am actually thinking long term at this
point not marriage i am 21 god damn it
and i wonder if this is if it's
if this is worth dealing with the
drawbacks of religious pressure
pressures and no sex for me the latter
is a pain because i actually cannot
masturbate just doesn't do it for me
which well so what are you doing during
those two weeks when you disappear
you're going to [ __ ] he's going to
[ __ ] town there
uh i cannot promise i will take your
advice but i will give it some weight
well then go [ __ ] yourself
what the [ __ ] is it that wasting my time
can we read the next question yeah
moving on
um from a lady
um
dear billy
[ __ ] that's funny
long time listener and fan
and incidentally a woman
so go figure that [ __ ] out anyways i
could use some advice i'm getting
married this november yes i signed up to
give away half of my [ __ ]
and this is well only if you're making
more than he is
um other than that you signed up for a
nice living room set
maybe a four bedroom colonial
my husband's such a jerk oh my god are
the sprinklers going off again
um and this is bringing up a lot of
family drama
my paternal grandmother hates my mother
my grandmother never felt like my mother
was good enough for my father oh jesus
and my mother
oh as my mother and i am very close my
grandmother has hated me since birth
and has always told me how ugly and
stupid i am what
is this precious
um
needless to say
i do not speak with her and haven't done
so in years after she made some racist
comments regarding my future husband as
he is mexican
the problem comes in when my dad insists
that she comes to the wedding
i have no problem telling my dad to go
[ __ ] off i do not trust him and we do
not get along
uh this screams a lope she should be
asking me these questions um my mother
and i
my mother and i
are very close
and he is using
that against me
um
saying if i don't invite his mother he
will make my mother suffer so do i
invite this [ __ ] grandmother to
potentially be a racist bigot at my
wedding or do i tell my dad to [ __ ] off
but hurt my mom in the long run um
i would just elope yep and i would have
a party in your backyard
yeah that's what i would do just go and
do it and then come back and be like
yeah we got married and
yeah
because i think there's so much
resentment and anger in that family and
so much lashing out that i think that
they need a clean start they need clean
slate
just go out and
tell the person that you're gonna be
with but what about his side of the
family if they love her and then they
want to be there
i know but it's like it's bigger than
that though you know right so it's got
to be the two of them and then
afterwards they have a big party yeah
and that's the thing i mean and you know
who's going to be there
tony mendez
ben affleck is tony mendez city hall or
whatever and just
do it that way and then you have a big
party later on or something like that
but um
i mean even if they have a party there's
still maybe is going to be these issues
did she say that her dad is married to
her mom or they're divorced
sounds like they're divorced
he's going to make life a living hell
for the mom
how would he do that exactly oh maybe
yeah maybe
yeah i mean who does that to somebody
they love
[ __ ] your dad is i'm sorry about that
that really you know you know it's it's
human beings
i don't understand how you yeah hey
say lovey i mean isn't the point of your
stupid podcast to have an opinion about
every goddamn little thing and then you
just want to wave your hand in the air
and be like that's human beings
that's life who are you where did you go
because you know why i'm [ __ ] driving
i'm texting while driving
to go down to get the juice today yeah
[ __ ] five minutes later i got the
juice i'm driving some [ __ ] [ __ ]
in front of me he's going slow speeding
up going slow speeding up i got this
[ __ ] asshole's texting and then i
look at him and i'm like [ __ ] idiots
texting blah blah and i was just doing
it
yeah so you're a hypocrite yeah right
but it doesn't mean you can't have an
opinion but am i unique and why am i
[Laughter]
you're not weak
you just know you're not weak you just
have no patience
you can't wait to your stopped somewhere
to do what you got to do oh jesus christ
didn't i just say how good you look like
you're coming at me like this
you know what no i don't understand what
this is you love me and you're worried
i'm gonna get hurt so it's coming out
this way right now okay i promise i will
try and stop texting i'll try and stop
yelling i'll try and stop being a piece
of [ __ ] i'll try to stop [ __ ]
i one of these days nia i'm gonna be
that guy
i'll be that [ __ ] guy i don't want
you to be anybody but yourself but well
then you know what
and you know what yeah
the thing is
is you think that like
if i scrape away all this [ __ ] what do
you think's underneath this the guy who
drinks the dolsekis with the cougar in
his kitchen that's not who it's going to
be i'm going to go back i'm going to go
the most interesting man in the world
i'm just going to end up being [ __ ]
eight-year-old billy
oh boy you want to go to the movies
tonight
i like with why i like that billy
no you don't yeah i do
what do you mean because this is the
deal when i
am actually
this when i
in the rare times
when i am in a chilled out mood
and i am going with the flow and
whatever you want to do i'm like yeah
let's do it and i don't question it or
anything
you get a concerned look on your face
and you like are you okay
are you okay and then i say what i'm i'm
i'm being the guy you want me to be
right now dedication of me that's about
that's that's how rare it is for you to
be that person that has nothing to do no
but i understand that part but then you
also said to me one time like well i i
don't want you to then you get like
concerned i don't want you to be
somebody you're not
right
so when this so when you see chilled out
me
it it like
you almost talked me out of it and i get
it to because to see chilled out me is
such a [ __ ] shock to you
that you want to make you want to go
[ __ ] you know
put your hand on my forehead to make
sure i don't have a fever right
uh yeah that doesn't mean that i don't
appreciate it
but yeah initially and that right there
is why men and women will never get
along all right here's the wrap-up
well right there nia it's just like
are you okay it doesn't you make him
feel like i'm [ __ ] weird because i'm
chilled out and then and then you go all
then you [ __ ] turn it all the way to
the other side it doesn't mean i don't
appreciate it is everything okay but i
like it what's wrong with you you're all
over the double line pick a [ __ ] lane
you pick a lane
we're gonna be right back
um all right the wrap up
i need a dj for this part
up uh now that the show is over don't
forget to sign up for your free trial of
hulu plus hulu plus lets you binge on
thousands of hit shows anytime anywhere
on your tv pc smartphone or tablet
support this podcast get an extended
free trial of hulu plus when you go to
the podcast page at billboard.com and
click the hulu plus banner should be or
click the hulu banner oh no it is and
click the hulu plus banner [ __ ] i was
right there or go to huluplus.com bill
that's huluplus.com bill you know what
to do um
hey and uh definitely check out that
youtube vid video you got to see the oh
jesus one whoever sent that one and that
was such a great find
uh
yeah who did the patriots have next week
who are we playing uh
that team from um
up there they won a few times
just just pick a name they lost a few
times
pick the name of the team you know the
the bears there the bears that's not bad
i don't know we're not we're not playing
that division let me let's see i'm on uh
scheduling stats
schedule season schedule bang
what do we got here
oh next week we're playing the bengals
who i heard are underachieving
that's what i read on the thing all
right well we shall see right
bengal tigers which are native to india
which is in
asia which is part of
asia which is part of the world what are
you talking about which is
a tiny dot in
the universe there you go
yeah but you kept going you had it
you're like india
asia
the world the universe yay
all right this is what the patriots have
come up these are our next three games
the bengals which i think that's a
dangerous game
all right they're a wounded animal those
bengals nene
they're backed into a corner
uh the saints is going to be a rough one
and the jets that's at the jets it's i
know they suppose they're supposed to
stink this week this this week this year
they're supposed to stink but we already
beat them and it's a division rivalry
and uh they always play as tough we had
a was it 13 to 10 it says right here um
23-21 when we played the bills those
division rivalry games i like taking the
under
um so anyways i don't even know what the
monday night game is this week but i'm
gonna try to get caught up on the
football
and uh
i'll tell you the broncos and seahawks
nene i think they're on a collision
course what do you say sure absolutely
huh so if you if if if a bronco
collide in a seat in a seahawk whatever
the [ __ ] that is i think that's a c it's
a seagull on uh roids it's a bird yeah
but when you look up seahawk you can't
find it other than the team i just
remember being like in eighth or seventh
grade and um the boys were wearing those
starter jackets and i remember the
seattle seahawks and it was like a bird
face
isn't that there yeah that's their logo
the logo
oh there it is is that what the [ __ ] it
looks like you know why because they
said they spell it one word
but if you just write c hawk
and then you just have the image dude is
there anything like more evil looking
than a a bird of prey let me see they
never look like they're in a good mood
like poisonous snakes they always have
like their eye their non-existent
eyebrows are always down
okay there we go
see that there's like that hint of anger
yeah that's what it looked like
you know what if you were a bird that's
the kind of bird you would be attracted
to
me i gotta stop dating these birds of
prey they're such an [ __ ] you know
what's funny because i was thinking when
you were describing like oh you'd like a
vulture i was like you're like i was
thinking that that was you no you'd like
a vulture with their redheads
you get me no that's what i'd be picking
at a carcass no you'd be like this you'd
be like a seahawks look i wasn't i
wasn't i wasn't fishing for a compliment
here i was just saying no no the these
are the guys you dated before you got to
me i'm not a bird of prey
and i'm not a bird of prey i know how to
make a pie
yes you do yes i do you know what i'm
like yes i'm a
[Music]
all right go [ __ ] yourself
that's actually the bad that's probably
the best one all right so you got the
last one in there you go yay all right
this week i'm going to be in el paso
this whole run i'm going to be with uh
rose bowl king rose bowl tailgate legend
joe bartnick we're going to be in el
paso on wednesday then we're going to
san jose on thursday and then i'm going
to [ __ ] seattle
um
we'll see how loud they are in seattle
then i'm go on on friday and then i go
to uh
phoenix
in on on saturday and that's it and
that's that's
that's that's that's [ __ ] it that's
where i'm gonna be all right that's the
podcast for this week thank you so much
for listening thanks for all the great
emails and the youtube videos
and all the people around the world
who've been listening uh
i really appreciate it that's it go [ __ ]
yourselves i'll talk to you next week